welcome to this video fantozzi autopsy I
don't know I'm going for them modern
again no I have a bad score against the
sky zero wins one loss two drawers okay
with this with this I don't know
experimental mode IAM ego are typically
you go on a plane oh it's really a five
minutes specialist step k our knight c6
he can go d 5 which looks kind of normal
this this should be all right here this
is like a king's indian with he has
played III e4 and so on f5 I mean even I
have six would have led to a king's
indian with an extra extra tempo okay
night coming to his six
yeah there's this idea with c6 I wonder
okay come on I'm just not pre moved
better not he might have been it was
pretty clear that he would put it on his
six but still very embarrassing pretty
move if it for some reason goes back or
something okay I'm just trying to with
c6 keep the night out of it and try to
get to the e6 pawn with Queen here he
has this attack on b7 of course yeah
similar positions can always arise in
the before variation of the main line
classical the bionet attack it's some
quite a comparable situation White has
ideas this line like c5 covering e6 for
the moment or yeah or this kind of thing
where you try to blast open the whole
position yeah Queenie six one thing in
my favor is the better development
German but that's that's it otherwise
the position is really somewhat shaky
okay let's see how c5
I didn't think about that at all I can
take the Queen right and f e
huh let's we had a very complicated
sequence here something like 94 94 fe 4
and then d 5 is this almost winning for
black but i wonder yeah come on let's
play this first night texas maybe even
better Knight takes e4 Fe Bishop takes
d5 and wide resigns basically but he can
take on d6 on d5 on e5 ah this is
interesting he wants to check on d6 now
thats it's a did sir and different story
it was clear that there was something
else happening than that what I was
describing me here
not clear at all I probably will emerge
with some extra pond but it's not a
simple win or Cameron to take you at the
porn i don't i don't think this was so
good because now well my bishop is
fantastic and the night is excellent on
d5 being yeah and testiclees ray this
porn limit suspicions enormously very
important okay so b6 and rookie a gem
possibly on it's not clear that i need
to worry about 95 that much i can go be
six when you place 95 yeah 97 look f 7 s
the kind of a self trap so it had to he
had to go back so is a6 a7 under fire or
not do i need to play a five look at
seven is also good move here covering
this and if he takes it i play rook f8
with a the pin that will win a p.m. i
said it wins apiece you're not agreeing
maybe yeah maybe maybe the deep porn is
an issue but as though i still do that
it looks it looks like the right move
maybe after this capturing sequence
there is d7 coming but so the sugar
should be a fled win if I take this on
now he will promote so I cannot do that
I can take care of them and I'm one
point up at least and still threaten
Brooke f7 ok check let's just trade some
stuff
m yeah mba 5m so that I can actually
move the rook sometime
yeah this way the pawns are very very
safe so this is always self pin in some
ways yeah it should be good now
making it a really serious pinned I can
take here oh wait is this Bishop you
five we should be 54 Bishop deform time
morning yeah Ruby five will also win
probably
I'm just being the component game I was
thinking I have an issue with the pawn
structure but that's not true it's not
not a problem at all I think
yellow yes fifth to take one g7 year
what is the farcical i did i did i miss
couch am i will win all the stuff now
that do here b 15 e form is quick enough
to get them a party he runs out of moves
at some point yes Jack bra Arthur can
believe this nonsense what did i do here
unbelievable not winning this is really
heartbreaking I'm actually still winning
check check check white forfeits on time
actually one on time at the end I would
have would have made it him for the
remove made Wow now that was terrible
technically I was Miss counting i was
thinking i thought i could stop the king
i thought i should stop the King summer
I made his probably it should still win
but I didn't didn't need to do that each
ball and it ultimately wins but he's
running out of museum until of course at
be five in a form that just just just
just wins very easily but ok with 20
seconds
now this is a draw check it just has to
play it right here yes this losers but
you can just go to g6 just get the h6
pawn is drawing so what was the easiest
win here tonight before must be good
yeah so Bishop takes was stronger yeah I
mean I saw that but I was simply you
know i miscounted sorry most too much
too many moves i miscounted ins I
thought that actually I would be only on
d5 year I was a for the funny funny
misconception this would have been very
easy of course I mean this wins but I
played it for the wrong reasons I didn't
see it see it correctly okay Wow tough
game thanks for watching